former president is on the campaign
Trail in Iowa this morning facing a new
challenge from Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis his top GOP rival The Stance
has met voters there yesterday and more
Republican candidates are headed to that
state as well which is where we find Ed
O'Keefe Ed good morning
Nate good to see you the former
president wakes up here in rainy Iowa
this morning ahead of meetings with
conservative activists and ministers who
can help rally the state's socially
Conservative Republican voting block
into his Corner he's also set to appear
tonight on Fox News the he's here after
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis made five
stops in 24 hours
crisscrossing the state before heading
off to New Hampshire today now the
governor Trails the former president and
National polls by double digits but he's
arguing to Republicans that Trump can't
win back the voters needed to win a
general election former president though
keeping close tabs on DeSantis as he
intensifies a tax on the governor's
management of covid and his ongoing feud
with Disney in a radio interview last
night he described the Rivalry with the
Santos's quote a war because he's
focused on who's in second place not in
say 8th or Ninth Place meanwhile more
candidates are jumping in the already
crowded race former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie set the luncheon's bid
next Tuesday in New Hampshire while
former vice president Mike Pence is set
to launch his campaign here in Des
Moines Gail for anyone keeping score
just about 220 days left
until the Iowa caucus
we are definitely keeping score Ed but
don't you think Donald Trump likes it
when more candidates come in the race
because then it just splits everybody up
and he's thinking more for me don't you
think he's saying come on in guys he's
and girls
history has proven that it works that
way for him in the past and there are
those that think it might happen again
so yes he's he's all for a crowded field
yep all right well we are always
watching thank you Ed always good to see
you Mr O'Keefe